welcome to las vegas in spanish your
digital connection to the world of
entertainment here in las vegas
salutes you natalia badly had today we start
talking about the biggest night for
latin music the grammys lines the
countdown to the
awards ceremony already started and with that
The announcements of the presentations of
various musical artists such as Christina
Aguilera, Carlos Jean, Bad Bank and Rubén
Blades, among other blades,
will also receive a distinction as Person of the
Year 2021 from the Latin Recording Academy.
vegas next thursday november 18 at the
mgm grand coordinate and let's not talk now about
the gay music festival in begues the
rapper travis cold should have
headlined the presentations
on saturday night but due to what happened in
blue he decided not to take part in that
event  so the artist post malone
will take his place there they are watching as
organizers of inveg  they say they will
take extra precautions due to the
astro ball game vegas tragedy
begins this friday
well there is a new streep dreams it
is about 'america's got talent' las
vegas' life at the boxster hotel and casino
this show will feature various
acts by  of former participants
of the television show including the
winners of its last season you can
see their presentations from Wednesday to
Sunday at half past seven at
night tickets are available via
agent vegas live.com ndong something else you
can do as a family is  visit the
mummy if the minister of the mafia and be
part of the nearly 3 million
visitors i hope to reach this number
this weekend or monday and
whoever this specific visitor is will earn
free lifetime admission to
mission mode a stay of  two nights at the
golden nugget among other prizes for
hours of operation voice visit
mission point or heretic
good if you're looking for fun with a
n twist  avideño I present to you the
elf bar the
grow lounge inside the casino has been transformed into
this Christmas place where you can
enjoy various festive cocktails such
as its martini with various sandwiches and
even interactive games but the fa
tends every day at five in the
afternoon and  they will open their doors until
january 2 at the casino de soul version
well before saying goodbye i leave the
entertainment aside to talk to you
about a special project for a
hispanic family here in las vegas there you are
seeing the velázquez family who
will be recipients of the
building hope renovation by the
organization of with the project brian
johnson those who are there on your
screens suffer
from duchenne muscular dystrophy and need the
help of the community to renovate their
home and make it more accessible to their
needs for more information on
how you can help bryant and
jonathan velásquez visit from webb deep
project.org
well until tr arrived  addition of las
vegas nao in spanish do not forget to
visit news now dotcom if you need
more information about these events
thank you very much for your attention
see you next week greets you nathalia mar tenido
[Music]